you know with all the controversy that
has surrounded the BBC in the last few
years I don't think I should be too
surprising that the one that seems to
have brought the most ire down on them
involves football
[Music]
so yeah I'm just going to talk about
what's been going on at the BBC just
straight up
and I'm not really going to put a lot of
pretense on this I've talked about the
BBC openly before and obviously it
impacts things in terms of
how I continue to deal with Doctor Who
because the BBC
obviously my issues with the BBC have
largely centered around their very open
and Unapologetic transphobia
continually platforming gender critical
Turf talking points and figureheads over
and over and over again while down
playing minimizing silencing and
ignoring the voices of trans people
literally ignoring there were protests
outside their offices that they ignored
and did not acknowledge but uh the BBC
stepped in it and the situation I am
about to talk about if you aren't
already aware of what happened well I'll
bring you up to speed but it has sort of
been resolved
however
I think it's still worth talking about
because it laid the hypocrisy and the
current standing of the BBC
bear
and the hypocrisy
became undeniable
so
we're going to talk about a guy by the
name of Gary lineker
now litiker was a professional football
player for a while but since 1999 he has
been a presenter on Match of the day now
that makes him the longest running
presenter in the history of that program
he's been doing it a long time he is
well liked
he was suspended
by the BBC
and he was suspended
over a Tweet now on the one hand you
might find yourself going oh cancel
culture again no not really because the
idea of cancel culture you know even
setting aside the bastardized version
that gets thrown around and hollered by
the far right what it is theoretically
supposed to be is a swell of calls for
accountability
you know from the general public that
then is responded to that's not what
happened here at all
there wasn't a big outcry against that
tweet
it was something that made clear his
feelings on a political situation and
don't worry we'll get into all this and
I'll give you the specifics
but the way the BBC responded
was incredibly telling
so
there have been
amongst many other things a lot of
issues with the immigration into the UK
and the UK's government's attempts to
close and lock it down that was honestly
one of the big supposed Promises of
brexit was to have more control over
their borders
and the right the Tories have been
pushing fairly uh xenophobic narratives
for a while and there have been a lot of
increasingly Draconian policies in place
or calls for draconian policies when it
comes to immigration now specifically
what he was calling out on Twitter
something called the illegal migration
Bill the specific aspect of that that he
was really hammering on was that that
bill would ban migrants who arrive on
small boats
and it would prevent them from settling
in Britain now
if you don't already realize if someone
has arrived on a small boat
like a rowboat a canoe
something with maybe just a single
outboard motor
they probably are in a uh rough
situation that is not a particularly
safe way to try and arrive in the UK
it's a bit of a desperation move now
whether someone is actually in a
situation that warrants that that's kind
of a case by case but just as a general
thing that is one of the most dangerous
ways to try and get there so he made his
feelings pretty clear about what he
thinks about the attempts to just flatly
ban anyone who arrives that way from
being able to settle in the country just
blanketly not Case by case not taking
into the consideration just saying you
arrive on a small boat you can't be here
that was the policy proposal and he
shared his thoughts now his original
Tweed that started all this was a
retweet of a video featuring interior
Minister suela Braverman outlining the
new uh Bill and what it was going to do
and he simply stated good Heavens this
is beyond awful
and when people started pushing back on
him on that he then put a second tweet
which appears to be the one that really
rankled the BBC specifically he said
this is just an immeasurably cruel
policy directed at the most vulnerable
people in language that is not
dissimilar to that used by Germany in
the 1930s now specifically the basis
under which the BBC Justified that
suspension had to do with their
impartiality rules
now the impartiality rules are something
I am familiar with because those were
the same rules under which for a Time
the BBC
forbade its employees from attending and
participating in Pride events
because that was considered to be in
breach of the impartiality Rule now in
theory the impartiality rules are there
so that the people who are members of
BBC's broadcast specifically anyone
related to anything in the news Branch
are not pushing policy only reporting
facts and that includes both in front of
and away from the camera these
impartiality rules do dictate off-site
Behavior so it's not just when they're
in the office if you didn't already know
freedom of speech in the UK is um
is not guaranteed to the degree that it
is in the U.S and I won't go down the
path of all the differences there but if
you didn't already know that
yeah
so those are the impartiality rules now
a big part of why this got called out a
lot
is because even if lineker did break
those rules and he may have as they're
written the fact that he was disciplined
when so many
right-wing figures who work at or
freelance for the BBC
repeatedly expressed their political
views and their stances and their
opinions on policy
and don't get disciplined this was all
laid out incredibly well by kavasolical
who made reference to numerous people
current and past who have been
affiliated with associated with or
employed by the BBC who in their time
there expressed right-wing policies why
is Alan sugar allowed to say what he
wants on Twitter about political matters
uh what about Jeremy Clarkson he's got a
column in the sun he frequently
expressed uh political opinions which
many people think are extreme and very
much like what we saw when the BBC tried
to wield the impartiality rules against
the ability of its employees to
celebrate Pride events
impartiality though in theory
being something that applies to all
political views is currently being
wielded as a cudgel against anyone with
more Progressive views than the Tory
party I.E the people currently in power
and that's not what these rules are for
but it's how they're being deployed as
how they're being used
and it's interesting
that the BBC blinked
tons of other sportscasters walked off
the BBC had to had to broadcast multiple
sporting events just showing the match
footage with no commentary because there
was nobody there to give it
they all walked out
and by and large
the public seemed to feel like lineker
was if not correct in his original
assessments and what he said not
deserving of this treatment
and the BBC has ultimately not only
restored him to his position this is the
part I love because we don't I don't
know to a certainty if this was one of
lineker's Demands for coming back
give it how stubborn the guy appears to
be I wouldn't be surprised but I can't
confirm this
but what is happening is not only is he
coming back the BBC is reassessing its
impartiality rules they wielded these
rules as a weapon
and not only did it fail to work because
he didn't cave he what they wanted to do
was go I'm sorry please bring me back
onto my show I'll behave and he didn't
he didn't he has said throughout this
entire thing I stand by what I said I
take nothing back
and I will not reverse my position on
this and I will continue to say it
publicly
he didn't budge an inch
they really thought he would
they wouldn't have suspended him if they
knew that this was going to happen they
would have let him get away with it
maybe unhappily
but if they'd known they wouldn't have
done this because it's not about
applying the rules it's about silencing
criticism of the current government
it's not about actually being impartial
it's about slamming the door and cutting
off and punishing
someone who is employed by what is a
government agency
and who is apparently supposed to just
shut up and toe the line
don't complain don't criticize and it's
especially telling that the BBC let him
openly on their programs criticize human
rights concerns in Qatar when the World
Cup was held there so they're not
against him criticizing a human rights
issue in another country and this is the
same guy in Indica who's been allowed on
the BBC to criticize the human rights
record of Qatar that's not considered
any kind of breach of the impartiality
oh those politics are somehow not
something we have to worry about oh
you're criticizing your own country oh
you're criticizing the people currently
in power oh no
but oh yes
he just stood his ground
he stood his ground and people rally
behind him and the BBC has not only had
to let him back but now they're going to
have to re-examine those rules
and I suspect when they rework them
they're going to be reworked in a way to
still attempt to use them in the ways
that they have I suspect
but they're gonna have to narrow the
field
because the broad strokes and how badly
and um unevenly they were applying these
rules
it's been spotlighted now they're not
going to keep getting away with it
this shows the importance
of standing ground
because the reason BBC and this is true
of many U.S
agencies companies Etc as well
fundamentally philosophically this is
the same is that
these people will
capitulate and say okay okay okay we'll
give you what you want person who is
making a stand we'll give you what you
want or we'll give you back the thing we
took from you
but just don't
just don't talk about any of this ever
again okay
I I don't know if it's as much a thing
in the UK specifically but
non-disclosure agreements they're huge
in the U.S
company will
put someone through something horrendous
illegal even
they'll pay them a settlement and have
them sign an NDA
and the company or the individuals
within that company won't have to answer
for it
and it can't be publicly known
and they bully people with that with the
promise of well it's either this or
nothing
but they actually can't get away with
that
not all the time
not in every situation unfortunately a
lot of times in the US they can simply
by threatening to tie things up in court
forever because they have more money
than individual people do but
if somebody has the means
if somebody can actually afford
to just stand their ground
if somebody's got enough money
which clearly Carrie lineker does and he
was happy to keep kick back and just go
no I'll wait
the beauty
of somebody using their means
for a purpose like this because like you
have to be a person of means to pull
that off you do
because if this had been you know I
don't know a camera person
you know someone low at low level at the
BBC had done this and been suspended
even if it was someone who's beloved on
set maybe there would have been a
walkout or two but like that person
wouldn't have been able to afford
financially to keep being suspended they
need the job they need the money
I
I am kind of an eat the rich person at
this point but this is is an example of
somebody leaning on their means
in a way that actually feels like it
produced some good because by standing
his ground for as long as he did until
they freaking broke
he got to just kick back secure in the
fact that he's well off enough to do it
and just wait
wait them out
the BBC
has always been a literal branch and arm
of
the current ruling government and that
has over the years at various times
tilted the
uh coverage of the news and the tone of
it one way or the other
but the degree to which it's happening
now exceeds what it's been before
this video I'm mainly
kind of gloating
I mean it's not like the BBC is suddenly
going to become better the BBC getting
better is going to be a long slog of a
thing if it can even be done
but
to see them break like this
given my issues ongoing and how long
they've been going on with the
organization
this was fun
this was fun to watch
to see them make a move that to them
probably seem very straightforward
see you bite them in the ass to see
lineker hold his ground turn out to be
way way too stubborn way more stubborn
than their processes we're accounting
for
and to see them cave
yeah
I won't lie I'm gloating
let me have this
for
years now the BBC
has been a source of little more than
infuriation
for me
and they make
my job difficult
and I like seeing them get their teeth
kicked in on this
I just did
not gonna apologize for it
but what did you think about what went
down
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it patreon pays the bills and
enables me to do this as my living even
if you can't assist me that way like
share subscribe also help me out but
don't worry too much about it
ultimately what I really want you to
remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
foreign
this video wouldn't have been possible
without my supporters over on patreon
and I would especially like to thank
Robin Moore Zubin look fulla Tarak the
thing that goes dark in the anime Ruth
Oliver B
ulurik Bogdan Melinda Walters imudelki
Leo the Boyd Auntie Kate 808 Becky
Sparks for Nabi lacks the poodle Robin
Powell Tracy scraven angry Casper Tim
price Adam RDL Taylor David Hall General
contact unit Problem Child Shayla
gourlay and Rosalind Bennett
thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]